look at the waves of
followership you get on Twitter you see
emojis swap out one after the other
get a face mask and then a Ukraine flag
a little BLM the The Pride rainbow
I'm not saying that people shouldn't
follow those things so they shouldn't
indicate their support but it's almost
like you see people following the next
current thing and I think that's because
we're alive in a time of um
more vacuum and post-religious vacuum
and so people are adrift and they're
looking for something to hold on to so
it's really important to decide for
yourself before you're just sucked up by
the next thing what your values are so
I've understood the place of religion
more which is no great
controversial new thing controversial in
some circle yeah but it's why people
have gone to church on the same day of
the week every week forever all day join
an allotment Club because being in a
community of like-minded people and
adopting a set of principles is an
anchor in an uncertain world